[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
83 de muscle
une bombe tu as vu ça une petite merde
la dernière petite merveille de
technologie technologie et de panel
sportif dans mon club excusez-moi
vous avez gagné 100 euros mais c'était
quand même mes 100 euros vous l'avez dit
je les récupère quand tu vois avec lui
calme-toi s'il te plaît merci et j'ai
oublié de te donner ton anniversaire ton
cadeau c'est quoi un cadeau oui on peut
il va kiffer il va kiffer
quel rapport à une passion Benjamin
c'est c'est pas juste la passion
[Rires]
alors comment ça avec la romance de la
semaine dans un instant j'en mettrai
plein la tronche à Castanet puisqu'il me
doit 100 €. mais d'abord donc la romance
de la semaine oui alors c'est l'indique
de la semaine vous avez pas vu une
petite différence si c'est pas l'année
dernière pourquoi parce qu'on met
toujours on remet toujours les trophées
les awards tout ça au mois de décembre
au mois de juin et cetera moi j'ai envie
d'un peu d'innover quoi j'ai envie de
faire un peu de la nouvelle téloche
[Rires]
quoi donc c'est la Ligue de la semaine
tout ce qui s'est passé cette semaine et
donc on commence avec la romance de la
semaine oui car de l'amour peut éclore
sur ce plateau
à votre avis vous vous en faites partie
non oui
c'est horrible
la romance de la semaine
[Musique]
il est complètement gay accusation
complètement à fondée sur tout lorsqu'on
voit les chorégraphies de Siri
[Applaudissements]
quand même bon c'est quand même l'heure
de la remise en question
je te dis un truc
on se regarde il y a un truc
oui il y a un truc ça c'est sûr il y a
un truc mais c'est plutôt dans ce livre
de normaux
[Musique]
c'est que tu penses que tu as le pouvoir
mais quand je veux mec je te calme
c'est bon
au revoir
et il est en train de voilà de gérer ça
oui on passe au top du quoi de la
semaine et si je vous dis oui peut-être
comment obtenir 10 kilos au moins
on fait penser à quelqu'un
[Rires]
Benjamin Castaldi l'homme qui me doit
100 euros et bien là toujours des très
gros problèmes d'articulation c'est le
t'a dit quoi de la semaine
le t'a dit quoi de la semaine
[Musique]
madame
j'ai rien compris
[Musique]
alors aucune idée
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable 30 ans de télé on sait pas
sur la route
on a rien compris on passe on passe au
focus de la semaine et j'ai une question
est-ce que vous pensez que les
chroniqueurs pensent vraiment ce qu'ils
disent lorsqu'ils débattent entre eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la grève SNCF enfin on est obligé de
prendre à cause des manifestants sur la
voie on est obligé de prendre la voie
petite vitesse donc 140 au lieu de 300
à mon avis qu'est-ce qu'il a dit de la
semaine
parce que ce sera vous la semaine
prochaine parce
c'est lui le faux cul de la semaine
le focus de la semaine
[Musique]
il doit quand il va à l'extérieur avoir
un très beau costume sur mesure mais si
c'est ça
vous l'avez vu Jean-Michel et Matthieu
ne sont pas d'accord sauf que j'ai envie
on le sait depuis 10 ans c'est un pro du
retournement de veste
[Applaudissements]
on passe au à l'heure du jaloux du
sommaire de la semaine oui attention
l'extrait est très très court mais c'est
quelques secondes vous suffiront pour
comprendre la vraie personnalité de
cette personne et celle-ci évidemment de
Mathieu Delormeau
le jaloux de la semaine
alors j'appelle Stan Wawrinka pour lui
souhaiter son anniversaire Stan Wawrinka
frérot bon anniversaire mon frérot
tu as regardé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
forcément d'autres choses oui d'autres
choses d'autres choses il s'est passé
très bien
le Charo de la semaine on passe au Charo
de la semaine et c'est ce Charo à votre
avis qui est le plus grand cookido de
l'intérieur c'est celui qui me doit
s'emballe Benjamin
alors là ce magnéto je le joue c'est sûr
et certain je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
l'impression que il a juré par Toutatice
[Applaudissements]
et vous savez quoi Cyril vous pouvez
jurer sur partout tatis qu'il est
l'approche de son 758e divorce bonjour
de la semaine
[Musique]
cette semaine on recevais donc deux
jolies influenceuses podcast et
Toutatice visiblement elles ont tapé
dans l'oeil et pas que de Benjamin
er
va-t-il résister à ça votre pas très
longtemps regardez
c'est reparti
[Applaudissements]
c'est une horreur
est un Charo mais il y en a qui est pas
un Charo mais qu'aurait pu l'être vu
comment regarder c'est vous ou Siri
le regard on peut pas le revoir au début
du magnéto alors bah je vois
rien comment vous regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il me dégoûte
on embrasse Toutatice et Paul scanner
d'être chroniqueuse pendant que Delphine
sera fort Boyard non mais c'est vrai il
y aura des places ça vous intéresse
très content
eh tu devrais faire sortir plus avec les
deux là non mais à base de chercher
l'intrus
tu sais Toutatice pour le Sky Daniel
Moreau
[Applaudissements]
allez soprano
c'est pour apprendre à respirer
bien-être des événements ceux qui
passent le Bac par exemple les jeunes il
faut ils peuvent apprendre à respirer
donc je vais passer le bac
[Rires]
sophrologie
on apprend à respirer ou gonfler le
ventre vous gonfler le torse vous
gonflement donc on fait le torse et je
vous assure vous ça marche
l'école pour faire arrêter de dire des
conneries
tu as d'autres choses oui avant de
repartir Cyril j'étais obligé de parler
du fou rire de la semaine vous l'avez
pas forcément vu à la télé ou la même
pas du tout vu mais figurez-vous qu'il y
a eu un fou rire qui est passé
complètement inaperçu je vous ai
rapporté les images regardez bien les
mouvements de bouche et regardez bien la
mauvaise foi de mon patron
le fou rire de la semaine
s'est mis en vrai manifestants on peut
dire pacifique qui venait pour
revendiquer les choses pourquoi pas
encore que la
terre
donc là vous avez vu Cyril Hanouna
j'entends un petit rictus vont-ils
réussir à ne pas partir en forêt vous
l'avez vu
les forces de l'ordre voilà je dis pas
que ce soit
des assassins
le décor est magique la maîtrise de soi
sophrologie à mon avis je suis pas moyen
mais ça devrait pas durer très longtemps
et j'en ai eu au téléphone je peux vous
assurer que les gendarmes ont eu très
très peur et pourtant
la surface qui est couverte par les
gendarmes est énorme on l'a vu hein
filtrer tout ça c'est quasiment
impossible et à un moment donné
effectivement on a retrouvé 60 boules de
pétanque des couteaux des vaches on
retrouve
tous les moyens qui sont possibles
qu'utilisent bon serrer la remet la
faute sur Guillaume il a fait sortir du
plateau donc c'est bon maintenant Baba
devrait retrouver son calme
c'est compliqué qui sont fichiers qui
sont connus
très bien il y en a plus de 2000 entre
2000 et 3000 euros Cyril c'est d'être
dur pour vous vous êtes auto exclu mais
pour calmer les situations vous avez
deux solutions soit remettre la faute
sur un autre soit faire un kite enfin
garde à vue systématiquement parce que
c'est pas possible qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
commis rien
[Applaudissements]